[Music]
as you know we are living in a world of
humans and machine humans have been
evolving and learning from the past
experience for millions of years on the
other hand the era of machine and robots
have just begun now you can consider it
in a way that currently we are living in
the primitive age of machines while the
future of machines is enormous and is
beyond a scope of imagination now in
today's world these machine or the
robots have to be programmed before they
start following your instructions but
what if the Machine started learning on
their own from their experience work
like us feel like us do things more
accurately than us might even start a
war of their own now these things sounds
fascinating and a little scary right
let's just remember this is just the
beginning of the new era now let's
suppose one day you went for shopping
mangoes the vendor had a cart full of
mangoes from where you could handpick
them weigh them and pay them according
to the fixed rate now the question
arises is how will you choose the best
mangoes you were informed that bright
and yellow mangoes are sweeter than peel
and the yellow ones so you make a simple
rule pick only from the bright yellow
mangoes you check the color of the
mangoes pick the bright yellow ones pay
up and return home right now when you
went home and tasted all the mangoes
some of them are not sweet as you
thought you concluded that when it comes
to shopping them you have to look for
more than just the colors after a lot of
pondering and tasting different types of
mangoes you concluded that the bigger
and brighter yellow mangoes are
guaranteed to be sweet while the smaller
bright yellow mangoes are sweet only
half the time the next time at the
market you see that your favorite vendor
has gone out of town now you decide to
buy from a different vendor who supplies
mangoes born from a different part of
the country now you realize that the
rule which you had learned that the big
red yellow mangoes are the sweetest is
no longer applicable here you made
another observation here that at this
particular vendor that soft mangoes are
the juiciest now let's suppose you go
out with your girlfriend
and she does not even like mangoes you
know how girlfriends are right and she
would like you to buy oranges for her
now all your accumulated knowledge of
what man was is worthless at this point
of time now you have to learn everything
about the correlation between the
physical characteristic and the taste of
the oranges by the same method of
experimentation but then again this is
not as difficult as you thought but what
if you have to write a quote for it so
as humans you would write a chord
something like this if mango is bright
yellow and the size is big that implies
the mango is sweet and if the mango is
soft that implies the mango is juicy now
conclusion as a human is that every time
you make a new observation from your
experiments you have to modify the list
of rules manually you have to understand
the details of all the factors affecting
the quality of the mangoes if the
problem gets complicated enough it might
get difficult for you to make accurate
rules by hand
that covers all the possible types of
mangoes now this will take a lot of
research and effort and not everyone has
this amount of time so this is where
machine learning comes into picture
well machine learning is a concept which
allows the machine to learn from
examples and experience and that too
without being explicitly programmed so
instead of you writing the code what you
do is feed the data to the generic
algorithm and the algorithm or the
machine will still logic based on the
given data now let's have a look at some
of the features of machine learning
which makes our life much more easier so
what it does is that it uses the data to
detect patterns in a data set and add
just the program action accordingly it
focuses on the development of the
computer programs that can teach
themselves to grow and change when
exposed to new data it enables computer
to find hidden insights using iterative
algorithm without being explicitly
program so know machine learning plays
an important role in our day-to-day life
as well you might not know it but you
are surrounded by a lot of examples of
machine learning and a lot of which is
something that you cannot live without
for example the first one is Google Maps
now Google Maps is probably the app we
use whenever you go out and require
assistance
in the direction and traffic now the
other day I was traveling to another
city and took the expressway and the map
suggested despite the heavy traffic you
are on the fastest route but that was
fine for me but how does it know that
well it's a combination of people
currently using the service the historic
data of the route collected over the
time and few tricks acquired from other
companies now everyone using maps is
providing their location the average
speed the route in which they are
traveling which in turn has Google
collect massive data about the traffic
which makes them predict the upcoming
traffic and adjusts your route according
to it now another application is the
product recommendation but suppose you
check an item on Amazon but you do not
buy it then and there but the next day
you are watching videos on YouTube and
suddenly you see an ad for the same item
you switch to Facebook chatting with
your friends and there also you see the
same ad so how does this happen well
this happens because Google tracks your
search history I recommends ads based on
your search history this is one of the
coolest application of machine learning
in fact you won't believe that 35% of
Amazon's revenue is generated just only
by product recommendation well here is
one of the coolest application of
machine learning by far it is here and
people are already using it and that is
the self-driving cars now machine
learning plays an important role in the
self-driving car and I am sure you guys
might have heard about Tesla the leader
in this business and their current
artificial intelligence is driven by the
hardware manufacturer in media which is
based on a type of machine learning
which is the unsupervised learning
algorithm now there are certain steps
which any machine learning algorithm has
to follow so the first step is data
collection and this stage involves the
collection of all the relevant data from
various sources now the second step
after collecting all the data is data
wrangling which is the process of
cleaning and converting the raw data
into a format that allows convenient
consumption now after the data have been
cleaned and converted into a particular
format the data is analyzed to select
and filter the data required to prepare
them all because not all the data is
required for a particular model you have
to select certain features
now after selecting the features the
algorithm is strained on the training
dataset through which the algorithm
understands the pattern and the rules
which govern the data after this the
testing dataset determines the accuracy
of our model and after this F model is
ready so the final stage comes is that
the speed and the accuracy of the model
is acceptable then that model should be
deployed in the real system and after
the model is deployed based upon its
performance
the model is updated and improved and if
there's a dip in the performance the
model is retrained the machine learning
is broadly classified into three major
tasks which are the supervised and super
and the reinforcement learning the
simplest from a machine learning is the
supervised learning and it is the one
where you have input variables like X
and an output variable Y you use an
algorithm to learn the mapping function
from the input to the output so in
simple terms it implies y equals f of X
now the goal is to approximate the
mapping functions so well that whenever
you get some new input data X the
machine can easily predict the output
variables Y for the data now let me
rephrase this in simple terms in
supervised machine learning algorithm
every instance of the training data set
consists of input attributes and
expected outputs the training data set
can take any kind of data as input like
values of datasets rows the pixel of an
image or even audio frequency histogram
now let me tell you why this category of
machine learning is termed as supervised
learning now this is because the process
of an algorithm learning from the
training data set can be thought of as
the teacher teaching his students the
algorithm continuously predicts the
result on the basis of the training data
and is continuously corrected by the
teacher the learning continues until the
algorithm is an acceptable level of
performance now any speech recognition
or any speech automated system on your
mobile phone
trains your voice and then starts
working based on this training data this
is an application of supervised learning
biometric attendance you can train the
machine with inputs of your biometric
identity it can be your thumb your iris
or your face for the matter of fat once
the machine is trained it can validate
your future input and can easily
identify you nowadays this is being
implemented in all these smart phones
that we have but sometimes the command
data is unstructured and unlabeled so it
becomes very difficult to classify that
data into different categories so
unsupervised learning helps to solve
this problem now this learning is used
to cluster the input data into classes
on the basis of the statistical
properties now the training data is a
collection of information without any
label here now mathematically
unsupervised learning is where you only
have the input data which is the X and
no corresponding output variables now
the goal of the unsupervised learning is
to model the underlying structure or the
distribution in the data in order to
learn more about the data so we came
across in a bottom point here which is
clustering so what exactly is clustering
so clustering models focus on
identifying groups of similar records
and labeling the records according to
the group to which they belong and this
is done without the benefit of prior
knowledge about the groups and their
characteristics in fact we may not even
know exactly how many groups to look for
but the models are often referred to as
unsupervised learning model since there
is no external standard by which to
judge the models classification
performance there are no right or wrong
answers to these models now market
basket analysis is one of the key
techniques used by large retailers to
uncover association between items and it
works all on unsupervised learning
it works by looking for combination of
items that occurred together frequent in
the transaction not to put in another
way it allows retailers to identify the
relationships between the items that
people buy for example people who buy
bread also tend to buy butter now the
marketing teams at the retail stores
should target customers who buy bread
and butter and provide an offer to them
so that they buy the third item like an
egg so if a customer buys bread and
butter and sees a discount on or an
offer on egg he will be encouraged to
spend more money and buy the eggs
this is what market basket analysis is
all about the reinforcement learning is
a part of machine learning where and
agent is put in an environment and he
learns to behave in this environment by
performing certain actions and observing
the rewards which it gets from those
actions this reinforcement learning is
all about taking appropriate action in
order to maximize the reward in a
particular situation in supervised
learning the training data comprises of
the input and so the model is trained
with the expected output itself but when
it comes to reinforcement learning there
is no expected output the reinforcement
agent decides what action to take in
order to perform a given task in the
absence of a training dataset it is
bound to learn from its own experience
now let's understand this reinforcement
learning with an analogy to consider a
scenario where and our baby is learning
how to walk now this scenarios can go in
two ways the first is that the baby
starts walking and makes it to the candy
since the candy is the end hold the baby
is happy it's positive reward now coming
to the second scenario the waving starts
walking but fails due to some harder in
between the baby gets hurt even and does
not get to the candy it's negative the
baby is sad that you implies negative
reward just like how we humans learn
from our mistakes by trial and error
reinforcement learning is also similar
we have an agent which is here the baby
and we have a reward which is the candy
with many hurdles in between the agent
is supposed to find the best possible
path to reach the reward now another
application of reinforcement learning is
also the games it is used to solve the
different games and sometimes achieve
superhuman performance but the most
famous one must be the alpha go and the
Alpha was zero it trained from the
scratch and a researcher led the new
agent alpha was zero play with itself
and finally beat the alpha go 100 to
zero now this was a major breakthrough
in the reinforcement learning process
and also helped a lot of people in the
deep learning process as well and also
the data scientist to make new robots
and create the artificial parts which
are there in the games so guys this we
come to an end of the session
I hope you understood the basics of
machine learning what it is what are the
basic types of machine learning how it
is difficult for us to perform all of
these scenarios by hand and write an
algorithm by ourselves
so guys if you have any queries
regarding this session please feel free
to mention it in the comment section
below
till then thank you and happy learning I
hope you have enjoyed listening to this
video please be kind enough to like it
and you can comment any of your doubts
and queries and we will reply them at
the earliest do look out for more videos
in our playlist and subscribe to any
rekha channel to learn more happy
learning